[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream Q&A section number
27 I am here with dr. Heather hi and we
are going to endeavor to answer your
questions about this that and possibly
the other maybe the other maybe you see
we get to it yeah but we wanted to start
by saying that our normal schedule would
have us doing our next live stream
number 28 on the 4th of July which
obviously is a meaningful day here in
the United States where many of our
viewers are from and we think we're
gonna go ahead and do it
expecting fewer people to be able to
tune in live no no you'll tune in its
fourth of July this is a very patriotic
podcast you'll be there but please bring
your own barbecue for kovat reasons we
cannot supply it for everyone that's
true yes yeah I thought I'd mention that
thank you thank you I know I feel better
yeah I heard that it'll be cheaper yeah
and then also for those of you who have
joined Bret's patreon of late at the
hundred dollar level you get access to a
lecture conversation on the way first
conversation on the first Saturday of
every month but that will be delayed by
week so you will also make an
announcement on your patreon recipe that
is that Coalition of the reasonable
discussion which has been fantastic
there are people who have been doing it
for years and I think we all look
forward to it every month because it's
it's a great reality check and we come
up with some really interesting things
which are now finding their way into
actual efforts to change the system yeah
so you'll announce this also to your
patrons but that that will not happen in
July 4th that will happen the following
Saturday and as long as we're talking
about patreon we did our first private
Q&A livestream last Sunday for Dark
Horse members which you had access to at
my patreon and I think it was a very
good success we got a lot of great
feedback so you can join you can join us
there as well that one it's a it's a
private link but you can see it at any
time
and we will be doing one of those every
single month private QA yeah I recommend
I thought there were some really great
questions and it was it was more
intimate because smaller number of
people so anyway yeah take a look at it
yeah all right
so we're gonna start as we did last time
by picking up just a couple of comments
questions that we got last time that we
didn't get to so for them first question
from last time
not from episode 27 but from episode 26
hi guys my girlfriend says that trans
rights activists make the distinction
between gender what you choose and sex
how you are born she seems to think that
you are misinformed
any thoughts so many thoughts yeah a
number one question is the girlfriend a
keeper right that really dictates which
strategy you use in response to this
question I don't think it needs to know
okay now I think you might as well just
go full truth on this one either way
actually you'll find out if she's a
keeper
yes consider it some sort of a test yeah
yes so gender which is what we call in
humans what we would call sex role in
other species is basically the
behavioral manifestation of your sex so
yes there is a distinction but they are
tightly linked and so it's all
evolutionary and where you draw the line
between what is quote unquote biological
and what is quite a quote social is
somewhat up to you although we tend not
to talk in those terms because the fact
is it's all evolutionary so the fact is
that gender fellows from sex sex is
binary gender isn't gender is the
manifestation of your sex traditional
gender roles we're much closer to
bimodal to to binary than they are now
at this point your sex does not decide
nearly as many things about what the
options you have in the universe are as
they did even even 50 years ago frankly
but the idea that gender is simply a
choice that is independent of what your
sex is or independent of evolutionary
process is wrong and I would say one
more thing which is that not only is
that true but trans rights activists as
compared to actual trans people who are
mostly not in our experience on board
with the tra ideology also pull a
mountain Bailey and the so they say this
as if it's an argument which it's not
but even if it even if it were they will
also then say actually even sex isn't
real so they have two arguments both of
which are wrong one of which is more
patently wrong than the other but even
the sort of the weaker form of the
argument which is that gender is a
choice and sex is biological isn't right
right so the tag line that I use is
gender is the software of sex and what
that does suggest is the gender is more
flexible it's varied it varies more
between cultures it is not perfectly
plastic but the thing that was in the
middle of Heather's excellent rant there
was that just the fact that something is
cultural rather than genetic does not
mean that it isn't evolutionary both of
these things are evolutionary they
travel separately through time so we
have this dual inheritance pattern and
gender is not perfectly free now can we
free it if we want to at this moment in
history we can but the idea that because
it is not encoded genetically that it is
somehow free from the logical rules of
the universe is just nuts
yeah which is not an attack in anybody
and and you know evergreen being what it
was we had numerous strands students
many more than we would likely have had
were we to teach somewhere else
we had very strong relationships with
them I you traveled abroad with trans
students so anyway it's I think the
thing is Heather makes this distinction
between trans people and trans rights
activists and I can't say what the
overlap is but I can say there are great
many people in the trans rights activist
movement who don't sound anything like
the trans people who we knew were
wonderful I think without exception
that's right and I guess we have
actually said a fair bit about this I
think I think there's a rebel wisdom
video of me talking about this and it
isn't a few places and it will can we
will continue to talk about this for
sure but one more thing that I will say
that I have said before is that if I
were coming of age right now as the
tomboy that I was people would probably
be telling me that I was trans and
that's simply it's offensive it's
regressive it's disgusting not that
being trans is disgusting but the idea
that I as a girl who didn't didn't have
stereotypical gender norms who far
preferred dirt to dresses and climbing
trees to playing with dolls was somehow
therefore revealing my inner inner truth
as a boy no I never wanted to be a boy I
liked playing with boys but it didn't
have anything to do with feeling like I
wasn't a girl nope just just abandoned
many other additional gender norms so
that was something that was true in the
70s and 80s which is now less true which
means that this is also the ideology
anyway is regressive it's actually
regressive it's actually sexist and I
would say misogynistic yeah and actually
you know you were the first person that
I heard make this argument I've now
heard several other people make it
including Katy Hertzog and I'm
forgetting as a list of three or four
amazing women who have now said
something along these lines JK Rowling
actually said this and so what are we
doing that we're tinkering with
something that makes amazing women I
mean it just it's a it's a crazy thing
to be messing with and you know it is it
is misogynistic and anyway it's gotta
stop yeah
all right so I'm this is a little bit
self-serving maybe but I'm reading this
comment from last time this is not only
the most important podcast but quite
possibly in all of modern history but
it's also the most prescient so that was
the word I liked here particularly
awareness of these issues is of the
utmost impressing importance I think
it's a little extreme I would say most
important podcast in the last 50 years
oh okay
next penultimate question from last time
what subject or subjects in k-12 school
were you least interested or proficient
in and then interestingly Jim not
included and I actually don't know what
your relationship Jim was but I love Jim
well I mean so far we had Jim in LA in
the 70s and 80s wasn't I seem like some
aspects of it like I remember climbing a
rope ceiling test yeah and then I
remember we had a dumb racetrack where
nobody had corrected for the fact that
the outer the outer path was longer kids
corrected for it because we knew but
whoever painted those damn life no they
just drew it like as a radiant oh my
goodness yeah it was it was almost like
you know scenery automatically filled in
by some sort of algorithm that wasn't
particularly well programmed but you
learned from that certain thing okay but
putting aside from Jim we had such
totally different experiences in school
and this again we could speak for hours
and hours about this and maybe we should
devote an episode at some point later to
just what school was each of us but I
mean I it's gonna be hard for me to come
up with something because you know even
the stuff that was good was such a
terrible failure in my case but I do
remember you clearly learned nothing
I'll show them right no the the I
remember learning the state capitals and
I remember thinking that I had never
heard of half of these cities and I
wasn't sure at what point it was going
to be
important that I had heard of them and I
just sort of felt like this whole thing
is on autopilot right yes state capitals
mattered a hundred years ago right and
yet you know so we were also of course
forced to work learn the states which is
relevant like if you're if you're in the
United States and frankly better
geography instead of being forced to
learn the state capitals
yeah being being forced to learn the
countries in Africa which you know
granted changes faster than the state
capitals but you know actual good
geography would be super valuable right
on the other hand you know I I granted
it's not that easy it would take maybe
you know an hour but they couldn't have
run us through like boundary layers
right or reversion to the mean or
something really useful content the
third grade yes the earlier the better
you just wouldn't use that language
necessarily no we certainly did with our
children when they were in third grade
but you don't you do it empirically you
do it right yeah no but I mean I will
say there's there's a again a ton to be
said here but I I loved school and I was
good at school and I specifically loved
English and arts and science and math
and the subjects that I couldn't quite
get into were foreign languages I took
French for no good reason and I just
made no sense to me learning it in that
framework and I don't have a particular
skill for learning foreign languages
anyway I now see having now lived in
french-speaking Madagascar and having
lived in Spanish speaking Latin America
I come it's it's not great but also
history like I had so few history
teachers that made it come alive that
weren't doing that sort of that sort of
learned the state capitals version of
history here's a litany of dates and
events without context without
explanation without analysis that I
couldn't fathom why you would be
interested in it that it really was only
through you know autodidactic history
but learning it on my own that I that I
came to really grasp but the big
exception there being actually that at
the
at the high school where we met
ultimately there was a great book a
great books program which really did the
sort of interface of literature and
history and so in that I did room and I
read I read Marx and I read Mao and I
read Lenin and Hobbes and Locke and
Rousseau and you know and Hume and Kant
and I don't remember most of it but I
still have the books and that that is
the way to learn the history and
philosophy of our country and of others
yeah but no no you were on that track
you were you were in the higher level
program so you got the great books I was
dumb tract so I was in the okay books
program which wasn't nearly as
interesting yeah you got Jack and Jill
climbing the hill oh man yeah I pretty
much figured out what was going on with
Jack and Jill but I you know I didn't
get Hobbes
remembered all of it every bit yeah yeah
no really school for me was a little bit
like a Milgram experiment trainer you
know which I passed every day from
second grade on I was not putting up
with that experimenters [ __ ] but no
I didn't get a lot from the content yeah
okay final question from a last time
where do you guys get your news these
days yeah you have to source it on your
own because every source seems to be
compromised if you tune into any sources
if it's good it's not good because
you'll get the [ __ ] that comes
through that same channel yeah so I
would say there are some places that I
look you know I definitely look at
rising which actually I will be on
tomorrow so rising is pretty interesting
the hill it's on the hill TV for me if
you surprising to me until yesterday on
the hill yeah and it's it's quite good I
definitely use reddit I there are
certain subreddits that I go to and
there are people who post things that
are useful and that will often point me
to you know when the Atlantic is saying
I will find myself reading stuff there
when it's insane I don't necessarily go
I mean I still stone Matt Taibbi has
been on fire he has been absolutely on
fire so Matt if you're out there keep it
up
go ahead I still have some print
publications coming into our house and
I'm more wary of some of them than
others but the Atlantic and Harper's are
two that I am mostly still appreciative
of the kind of long form journalism that
they do I had to give up on other Jones
unfortunately the New York Times is
pretty much lost I do scan the New York
Times and Washington Post's in The Wall
Street Journal and The Guardian well you
know all of us even the Wall Street
Journal are you know less so but you
know left-leaning enough that you that
you're definitely looking with the
particular lens spectator yeah sometimes
the Federalists sometimes not so anyway
the other thing is nobody has really
described the method but through Twitter
and other things using people you trust
to help filter the garbage so that
you're seeing the stuff that actually
has content is a very useful process yep
okay first question from the livestream
that just ended it seems that occupies
focus on economic inequality was closest
we've been to striking at a real enemy
agreed
has shift to the more superficial or
divisive concerns after Occupy but an
engineered strategy to move discourse
away from economic realities was
occupying threat to the status quo I
would say it was a threat to the status
quo and and had one significant
accomplishment it lodged the idea of the
99 percent which is not a precisely
right idea but it's an accurate enough
idea so to me the 99 percent if you can
just get people to look at it and say
there's a 1 percent and there's a 99
percent and somehow policy is serving
the 1 percent to the extent that that is
accurate it raises a question how the
hell are you gonna get a democracy to
make policy in favor of one percent and
against 99 percent it would seem like
every single election there would be a
campaign to have policy that served the
people enacted cynically or not right
that would be a hugely popular program
so how is it that you keep that from
breaking out in a democracy if you can
figure out that that's the question
now you know what's going on and now you
know why we have a move that has decided
that all of the inequities in the
universe are due to racism that can't be
seen or detected with a any tool of any
kind but it's there and I can't be cured
but it must be right that's how we got
there right we're doing this instead of
addressing the obvious glaring problem
that argue that occupy was initially
targeted at which frankly the initial
Tea Party was also targeted at so both
of those movements got co-opted and they
became silly or worse in the end and
we're now seeing occupy 2.0 fused with
black lives matter that's now explicitly
true we are seeing occupy revived inside
of this movement oh I didn't know that
that's it was it yeah where did I just
see it there's a Occupy protests in New
York and I've forgotten what it is that
they're oh yes it's an Occupy something
or other that is demanding a 1 billion
dollar reduction in the police budget
something like that so anyway yeah it's
a New York City police budget yeah yeah
that'll help what could possibly go
wrong
can't imagine um so anyway yeah it was
it was a threat it was defanged
the idea didn't go away though you know
the 99% is not invoked very often
anymore but it definitely penetrated the
public mind it did yeah and now I would
say take a look at the hidden tribes
report the hidden tribes report
describes an 86% in the middle of people
who have more or less shared values but
are very tired because we were being
pushed around by fringe ideologies on
both the far left and far right so
that's kind of I saw somebody invoke it
yesterday
so that is Mayor said Jonathan Hertzog
but anyway the idea was we are the 86%
which i think is great yeah that is
great it's a little it took my brain a
moment to switch that 86% is not within
same reference to the 1% right it's it's
a it's a totally different metric well
it was the innovation of whoever made
this tweet if it was Jonathan or not but
but somehow just as somehow the 1% is
making policy and the 99% can't figure
out how to get policy made on its be
the 40% appears to have captured at
least the DNC and presumably much of the
RNC as well the 86 percent in the middle
is not getting its needs taken care of
because the two fringes are pushing
around the the policy so anyway it is a
similar glaring defect in our system
that needs to be addressed yep okay
unity 2020 is the plan
unity 2020 is the plan to be awarded
enough electoral college votes in order
to put the decision to the house if this
isn't the plan please elaborate on your
specific path forward which states show
the most promise for a dark horse what
about Kasich yang my crowd seeing it cry
such yes it's catchy um so let me
address these in sequence one we thought
our biggest obstacle was ballot access
it turns out there are at least four
paths to ballot access that would not
require this to be thrown to the house
so all I will say is it does not make
sense for us to discuss the details of
that plan yet that actually we will
remove some of the potential by
discussing them ahead of time in other
words people who are not interested in
seeing us restore power to the people
will take up arms against it and the
more they know the worse off we are but
what I would say is stay tuned you will
very quickly discover what those routes
are and we can talk about which ones are
most likely and it may be that it's a
hybrid strategy but there are ways to do
it we were actually pleasantly surprised
when we looked into this matter and as
far as Kasich yang which states show the
most promise and what about quesadilla
well it's not a which states we're
talking about all 50 states and this is
plausible
we you know we tried to talk ourselves
out of this because if it wasn't really
possible we didn't want to put our necks
out but we ended up talking ourselves
into the fact that this is possible you
know what you can do to make it more
possible sign up add to our numbers it
costs you nothing it takes no time and
if you do it then people who are looking
at us thinking that's a really cool plan
but it's never gonna work those people
will start to come over and what you'll
get is positive feedback and positive
feedback as you know is the most
powerful force in the universe so
let's get there all right the last
question
Kasich yang you know we have a list of
people who if either yang or McRaven are
not available for this or are unwilling
and frankly I don't think either of them
would be unwilling but there is a
question about can they and if they
can't then we have a list of people who
could slot in either place you will
notice in our document the articles of
unity we do not mention any candidates
because the important thing is the plan
and there are great many people who
could inhabit either of these spots and
would do an excellent job because of
course
the key to any administration is going
to be who it's listening to right who is
it going to bring in to decide what to
do about environmental questions about
economic questions about the danger
posed to us by our enemies nobody's a
superhero people don't have encyclopedic
knowledge of how the world works on
every topic so it's going to be a
question of who they bring in and how
they make decisions and if they're
patriotic and they're courageous and
they're capable and they bring in the
right people why are we on a better path
next question is depression an
evolutionary adaptation if so then
what's the benefit the cost incurred
seems extremely high mm-hmm you want to
go over so I would say first thing is
the person to go to on this is Randy
Nesi who actually is a friend of ours
from when we were in graduate school I
took several did you ever take anything
from Randy it was in seminars with him
but no classes so anyway he he is a
important force in in evolutionary
medicine in Darwinian medicine he wrote
a co-wrote one of the most important
books why we get sick with George
Williams who is now deceased but in any
case they kicked off Williams who was
one of the most important evolutionary
thinkers of the 20th century 20th
century absolutely and also was a friend
of ours he was quite quite old but
anyway he is now gone so Nessie's point
I hope I don't butcher this Randy I
would say Nessie's point with which I
would agree is that there is a lot of
evolutionary content in too
in other words it's not a total failure
of the system it is a feature of the
system that is adaptive that we see
emerging in very harmful ways that
modernity has taken circuits that do
something useful and it has unleashed
them in ways that are harmful and so
like that but I would just say and a
fine a little piece you know is
paralysis an evolutionary adaptation yes
it is when you're asleep it keeps you
from hurting yourself right do we
sometimes see people paralyzed when
they're awake we do
why would paralysis exist that seems
like a terrible thing well it is if it
happens to you at the wrong moment and
it's a very important thing if it
happens to you at the right moment and
so the suggestion yes the depression
will be very much like this so and that
does it there's a nuance here that's
really important that the argument is
not the category isn't real depression
isn't real or paralysis isn't real
but that the other contextual factors
that exist at the same time change the
answer to whether or not it's adaptive
right so saying sometimes yes sometimes
no does not mean that we are calling
into question the reality of the
category and that I think this is
actually a key point that many people
who haven't thought evolutionarily a lot
may not into it we miss yep and I would
the risk of confusing people I would say
that the same thing will turn out to be
true for suicide itself which is
obviously a downstream con consequence
of depression but that historically it
was a very different object and that in
modern times we frequently see very
tragic meaningless suicides as a result
of noisy data person can't figure out
where they are and what it means and you
know I think we all feel that all the
time and the fact that it triggers some
people to to resort to suicide is maybe
not too surprising it's also addressable
if you think about what that implies so
maybe we should do that too
next question I'm a lesbian and was told
by several very masculine trans women
that I need to quote get over my vagina
fetish this seems eerily similar to
conversion therapy to me and as someone
who went through conversion therapy as a
youth this concerns me thoughts it
should concern you it's wrong it's it's
simply wrong and we all know what a
lesbian is and that's not it
this is why the I think this this is
part of the evidence of the conflation
of gender with sex this is and actually
you know so I have I know a person I'm
gonna anonymize her somewhat who is a
lesbian and it was in a relationship for
many years and her partner transitioned
and became unrecognizable to her and she
broke up with the partner now
identifying as a male and is now with a
new partner and the thing that my friend
said to me about her new partner with
whom she's been for several years now
was not only did my previous partner
change in personality at the point that
she was transitioning but I also
realized that the changes physically
were unappealing to me and I've come to
understand something that I wouldn't
have allowed myself to think before
which is that I this friend of mine
actually really prefer very feminine
women you know that I that that's that's
just the the phenotype that I like and
I'm being made to think that this is
bigotry and the fact is like I've chose
this this woman I'm with now this love
of my life
is a very slight feminine woman and if
you had asked me 20 years ago I mean
this woman is a total badass you know
she's very she's butch but she's you
know she's very physically at Devon it's
probably a tomboy yourself and all of
this and she's saying I'm just I'm just
not gonna be ashamed of this anymore
like this is like this I'm in love with
this woman and it turns out that this
woman happens to have the body type etc
that I am also attracted to and guess
what that's part of what being a lesbian
is
being attracted to women not natal men
who have declared that they're women no
matter how much other things they've
undergone and not to say that some
people who are lesbians wouldn't vote
but the whole thing is ludicrous the
whole thing is complete false this falls
in Douglas Murray's category of things
we knew until yesterday that's really
good it's a how the [ __ ] is it that some
man is telling a woman that he needs to
get over her vagina fetish is not sexual
harassment or worse yes how is that not
obvious how is this not obvious I mean
basically I can't imagine if I was on
the jury and she flat-out hit this
person I think he'd asked for it if yeah
if the person writing the question had
flat-out hit this very masculine trans
woman directed to them and probably have
sex with them in order to demonstrate
your lack of transphobia until yesterday
Douglas Murray's schema we knew that
this was insane yeah we knew right and I
think the correct response might be
something like good go back to arguments
cool because that isn't one oh yeah okay
thank you
next question thank you to for all you
do here thanks also to your son yes ak
yeah can you help me understand what the
attributes of a Maoist Revolution are
I'm having trouble wrapping my head
around the concept whoo that's a big
question well I mean let's first of all
we will be attacked for saying that this
is a Marxist revolution even though
leaders of BLM have said into a camera
that they are trained Marxist trained
Marxists and that's what they're about
but nonetheless that we will still be
wrong asserting that they are even
though they have asserted that they are
and many of their talking points are the
same ones as other people who have
identified their movements as Marxist of
using things like looking to dismantle
the nuclear family yeah right but I
would say I mean and then sorry but that
like the dismantling of a nuclear family
is actually straight out of Marx you
know he finds I think I think Marx and
Engels in
the Communist Manifesto specifically say
that the you know that you have to go
after the nuclear family as though sort
of the center of the bourgeois thinking
before you can actually but as it sees
the means of economic power etc etc said
I don't have it here but yeah but think
about this right this has everything to
do with cults breaking your connection
to your friends and your family in order
to invade your mind yeah because they
need to deny you the reality check and
so going after the nuclear family is
multifaceted here there is a problem
with the nuclear family in black America
as I have argued it very plainly where
does it come from it comes from a sex
ratio difference where a large number of
men are taken out of the mating pool and
what that does is it undercuts the
bargaining position of women mating and
dating in the black community this is a
perfectly predictable demographic fact
that has nothing to do with being black
so that thing then causes men not to
stick around why because men who have
lots of sexual options are harder to pin
down you know you can ask any woman with
common sense if that's true and they
will tell you that it is so this is a
predictable catastrophe but rather than
address the causes of the catastrophe
they want to tear up everybody else's
family which is insane right the nuclear
family is very important it's very
important for many reasons including
your nuclear family will provide you a
reality check when people tell you crazy
stuff and insist that you say it too so
it is it is in deep need of resistance
there was some other part of that
question what was it yeah well it's what
are the attributes of a Maoist
revolution oh the horizontal nests right
okay the fact yeah this thing comes at
all of that you know it comes at the
people close to it in the form of those
they know and then insists that they you
know it also uses the youth to spread
the word at first young that the
Redguard
were even high schoolers high schoolers
and college students who then who
basically denounced the would-be
authorities and shamed people into
comply
and put placards around their heads and
made them publicly swear oaths and such
yep
the struggle section is the key defining
feature yeah can we replace the concept
of checking your privilege with
something like share your blessings
the idea being inspiring gratitude might
work better than making people feel
guilty that would be more effective that
suggests though that the people who are
asking you to check your priveledge are
actually interested in changing things
for the better
and I think many of them are not but I
agree that gratitude is a far more
effective and loving and generous
emotion and ploy to use with people in
part because real gratitude isn't fake
about right just like you know real
apology is so valuable and real
gratitude is so valuable because they
are inherently honest you know it also
strikes me that there is a verification
as in versus falsification ISM take and
a type 1 versus type 2 error take here
in the sense that if you are if you are
focused on what is wrong then you may
view the world through very dark lenses
and you may have the sense this thing
has got to go right if you instead look
at what's going right then you would
understand that you can't possibly
afford to tear up Western civilization
because if you do you'll be way worse
off which does not mean that you should
not be demanding a fix for what's wrong
but it means that up ending the part
that works because you're not noticing
it where you're discounting it is just
self-destructive as all get-out i used
to say and it's it's hard to make the
suggestion and the era of kovat but i
used to say and i and i lived this both
through what i and we did but also
through running all those study abroad
trips over the years is that before you
become super entrenched as to what you
think is wrong with the US and our case
go live and be among other people in
another culture in another nation-state
for at least a few months better if it's
for longer and then come back and see
what functions here that doesn't
function
elsewhere and you know better the more
of those other data points you have
and yes it's your life and you're not
doing it scientifically therefore it's a
series of anecdotes but there is I
remember few other moments with as much
clarity as coming back to the US after
the first of our long first just
adventures and then field seasons and
just being thrilled for instance at
knowing that there was going to be water
that came out of the tap and the roads
were going to be paved and the
electricity was going to stay on yeah
yeah it's it's a tragic irony of the
situation that really the you know the
missing thing is something against which
to calibrate right how do you know
whether civil Western civilization
really sucks until you've seen an
alternative and you know you could
indirectly figure it out by how the rest
of the world views us it's not that we
don't they don't get the proper data
about how dumb we can be and how broken
things can be but they also get the idea
of how much works which you know if you
just promise there is how much promise
and yeah so again none of this is a
defense of what's wrong but right but
yes the amount that functions is
astronomical and rebuilding it from
scratch for no reason because you've
discounted its value is is insane it's
not yours to destroy because other
people are depending on it and some of
them know it massive thank you to you
both and to the people not on screen
that's use Eck damocat and yes the cats
I'm worried that with the high
unemployment going around we might see
things deteriorate even further rather
than stabilized how do we encourage and
guide unemployed people during this time
I understand their plight but I'm not
sure how to be part of the solution um
they need to hope people I mean I don't
know how to emphasize this I think the
major difference between what I and I
think you see going on and most people
who align with us in terms of values the
primary distinction is the timeframe
right we do not have long to fix this
problem we have a history of inferring
how long processes take that is
misleading us it's leading us to imagine
that we have a great deal more time than
we actually do but we also have a quick
opportunity right we are four months out
from an election that could change
things for the better
that's a sprint that is not a long
period of time you can hold your breath
that long so the point is people need
hope if they understand that there is
light at the end of the tunnel that
something is coming that might work they
will be in a very different place than
if their sense is this is our life until
we do something about it and what are we
being told is the only thing to do about
it tear it up all right
that's what they're gonna do until they
have some reason to hope that things are
going to get better and frankly I am
very troubled by what happened to hope
under Obama that the abuse of the
concept of Hope the fact that we can't
invoke it without feeling derivative
that is a danger to us because hope is a
fundamentally important thing to keep
people on track and focused on what
matters and when they lose hope they
behave like people without hope which is
to say destructively and they make no
attempt to preserve that which is
important so hope I think is the answer
a guy named Eric hopper asks on the 25th
Dark Horse podcast you kept mentioning
issues being in the hopper what do I
have to do with any of it well let me
tell you very little I would imagine
yeah I mean you could probably help yeah
Dennis Hopper either as far as I know ya
know we haven't heard from him no not
yet okay
what if we play offense we could start
with our own open letter demanding that
all 1,200 health experts on the original
open letter be fired for compromising
their profession defense is retreat yeah
offensive but yes
I'm all for offense oh yes oh we are we
are shining a light
but it also it also can feel a lot of
what we're hearing from people is
they're feeling ever more cornered and
we know once you're cornered you have to
start by fighting off what's happening
before you can get a place to stand
where you can start doing offense I
think you know the thing is we need
careful offense that's the sort of the
art that we are learning through the
weird trajectory we've been on for the
last three plus years a little
experiment go to your Twitter feed look
at the hash tag tag black lives matter
at the moment right I think this may
have changed in the last hour or so but
I think you will find my tweet at the
top of it right and my tweet describes
what I think that motto should mean and
what it has clearly come to me and you
will see I don't know thirteen thousand
likes
so saying anything bad about black lives
matter is a disaster now except if you
can learn how to make a critique that is
robust yeah you think I'm gonna be
canceled by the end of the day I don't
think so yeah and using the using the
hashtags without don't use the hashtags
and throw fire bombs
oh but use the hashtags for careful
critique that people who also appreciate
careful critique start making it trend
such that people who don't know anything
about the critique may search on the
hashtag and see it and just a little
seed is planted yeah well anybody who
goes to that hashtag who's not paying
attention who thinks yeah black lives
matter hell yeah right yeah well they're
gonna find this at the top at least for
the moment and so my point is that is a
foray into enemy territory and it is not
vindictive
I think it's generous it says yes black
lives matter if that slogan actually
implied that black lives are undervalued
and we must do something about it then
many of us including me would be on
board at the head of the the charge but
but in the current situation I can't so
anyway forays into enemy territory
figuring out how you can do it in such a
way that it's careful enough that you're
canceled resistant it's a learned art
but one worth learning and
maybe it's the coin of the realm for the
moment yep as intellectuals and parents
of assumedly typical albeit patriotic
highly capable courageous teenagers what
is your advice for practical and
effective steps that k-12 schools can
take to semi safely open in the autumn
mmm hashtag unity 2020 yeah well we know
how to make it safer we know more time
outside greater spacing between people
open windows and I would say open you
know the windows open doors increase air
flow yep increase air flow like fans but
increased air flow with outside air yes
increasing air flow with entirely inside
air does not seem to reduce infections
much if at all and in fact those who are
in the line of the air flow are more
likely to get sick well I think it
depends how much you scrambled the air
but yes given a haphazard scheme it
probably wouldn't work but at least in
the autumn air from outside pumped in at
a high rate spacing between people I
mean it's just tough if you live in
Minneapolis you know what are you gonna
do in January you're not gonna have the
doors open well does anybody live in
Minneapolis in January I'm sorry I
apologize we lived in southeast Michigan
for 30 years well we were tropical
biologists it was the obvious choice I
made a point of going to Madagascar for
most of those northern winters yeah yes
not most some so the other thing is
there are technologies that we could
bootstrap that would help this right
like here I'll dump one into the public
domain because I'm not very well going
to patent it at this moment
well how about lights that pump out UV
spectrum stuff when nobody's in the room
yes yes how are that yep and
the thing that many of us said but which
you know Oregon as of July 1st everyone
was required unless they're in a private
space if they're inside to be wearing a
mask and we've talked a lot about masks
we started off our very first episode on
March 24th talking about masks I hate
them I hate wearing them but I wear them
because even if it weren't mandated it
is it is the best most effective route
now I don't know about second graders
you know for most in most places kids
under 12 are exempted but they would
love this mask they would you give yeah
at least the boys you know training and
study how do we excite the gender
typical girls oh they'll figure
something out
you don't think if you gave them a
bandana they'd figure something out yeah
I think they would you think they might
yeah okay if leaders fear losing their
jobs why don't use a tactic from their
playbook and adopt the strength in
numbers move you can't target what is
everywhere I have ideas in the tech know
how to implement solutions please
contact cool I would say I wonder what
happens if and how can this not be a
thing that we have seen you know if one
workplace had just by accident it had
more courageous people by a significant
degree who managed to find each other
and talk about this without outing
themselves too early and then mounted
some kind of useful careful resistance
you would have a workplace in which the
opposite thing had unfolded right and
that would become a model yep so it must
not be allowed how do they prevent it
from ever happening I really want to
know if it worked once what would happen
next because that has to be an
interesting story are you really
okay well we're going to do a couple
more here I was at 2:15 we switched over
to this round of questions so we'll go
probably an hour and fifteen minutes
here a suggestion for someone named dr.
Steven poorhouse or poor guests I don't
know on the podcast discussing polyvagal
theory suggests and someone else who
looks to be speaking to the other people
in chat but recommending a thread on
Twitter about the current political and
cultural moment for someone named at
Adrian Lee Oliver do you know who that
is
yeah next question why are some humans
more energetic than others
assuming caloric intake is pretty
similar across the board what explains
that some people seem to have such
differing amounts of energy than others
is it all just perception I would say
it's development on perception yeah it's
development you know the there are
certain things that rarely get mentioned
that haunt every discussion in which
they're absent one of them has to do
with development we often talk about
what people are like but we don't talk
about the process that makes them that
way we certainly don't include it in
evolutionary discussion that's nearly
often enough and so I think the one that
educationally I found was absent from
almost every discussion was one of
motivational structures that is to say
what is it that you find that causes a
reward to be released internally that
has everything to say about what you're
gonna be able to get yourself to do and
what you won't be able to get yourself
to do so we are all hobbled by a
motivational structure built for an
environment in which we don't have
enough food which almost all
environments have not enough food for
the creatures that live in them for
automatic reasons any population that
has too much tends to grow until it
doesn't have too much so what that means
is that our physiology and our
neurobiology are wired around getting us
not to spend energy right because
spending energy is an energy you have to
replace by finding more food if you can
preserve it so this causes people who do
not have a developmental experience that
that gets them to value what half
when you are energetic tend to default
to being sedentary which is very
dangerous we have too much food most of
us and so what that means is we'd be
better off to burn more but it's very
hard to convince your physiology of that
when it has what's probably billions of
years of nearly unbroken privation so
this is a it's a it's something we trip
over because our environment is very
novel which is of course the subject
primarily of our upcoming book what
happens to creatures that find himself
in a novel environment like us I guess I
would add one thing at the mechanism
level which is hormonal so in keeping
with the focus here on development let's
skip from this more sort of poly
hormonal expletive energy because
there's a lot of factors that go into
that but certainly it is hormonal II
mediated one of the reasons that you
know going back over into the trans
discussion one of the reasons that many
of us object to the idea that you can
simply transition from being a man into
being a woman full-stop is that hormones
aren't just on-off switches that toggle
on and then you're experiencing the
effects of estrogen to progesterone or
testosterone or other androgens and
toggle off those are the so called
activational effects which are in the
moment but there are also organizational
effects and you know this is a rubric
that is used by many endocrinologist not
by all and it's you know it's a it's a
it's a schema for how hormones work but
organizational effects are those effects
that basically organize or create the
background anatomy and physiology on
which later developmental anatomical
physiological in technological effects
can happen and so if you go through
puberty for instance as a boy and become
a man and then decide that you are going
to switch into in you're going to
transition the fact is that your body
was organized hormonal E by testosterone
on the other hand urgence and you can't
ever undo those effects and so it will
never be fair for instance for you to
try to compete against women
so there are similar but with many more
hormonal inputs explanations for things
like diet and energy that how it is that
you have your early childhood and
especially puberty adolescent
transitions with regard to the hormonal
inputs how much exercise you're getting
what kinds of foods you're eating you
can't simply change all of that and as
an as an adult and erase all of the
effects from when you were a teenager
those won't totally disappear there were
organizational effects that your you are
now going to live with forever mm-hmm
yeah absolutely which is the the death
knell to the argument that people should
be allowed to transition very young or
just have their puberty stopped until
they know right because you can always
do it and the answer is you can't always
undo it yeah this is a permanent affect
you know not as severe as a surgical
modification in some ways but every bit
is physiological yeah thanks question
you have argued that blacks deserves
something due to their origin story why
should they not be viewed as any other
individual born into adversity for any
number of reasons does it matter what
group they belong to yeah but this
sounds almost like an argument about
reparations it's not like deserve like
compensation it's like dessert let's
just be clear you have not argued for
reparations I have argued that
reparations are justified by the history
but that they are such a terrible remedy
that we would be stupid to institute it
and that there are remedies that would
work to do the job much better and
wouldn't head us into very dangerous
waters from which we probably would not
recover and just asterisk Coleman Hughes
writes extraordinarily well on the
question of reparations and why he
thinks it's not a good idea yeah I think
frankly a lot of people who've thought
very carefully about it including a
great many black scholars recognize that
it's just not a good remedy um but
anyway the point is deserve you know why
do you deserve to have a healthy
environment well in that sense that's
the sense of deserve that I mean every
American should have access to the
necessary prerequisites to
live a decent life in to the extent that
people are born into circumstances that
they don't have the tools to get out of
by virtue of the way things are
distributed or special hazards that
afflict some communities and not others
that's just not decent so we have an
obligation to fix it and what I've said
before is that Native Americans American
Indians and American blacks have a
special case it's not the same situation
as populations that came from elsewhere
in the world which did face racism but
we're able to overcome it these two
populations have a special set of
obstacles that come from the origin
stories and they mean those special
obstacles require a meaningful remedy
which we haven't yet fully hit upon but
I think it's readily doable I can't
imagine why we wouldn't and it is the
decent thing so let's do it okay we're
gonna switch to the questions that have
come in this hour and go through as many
as possible in the order in which they
came in Brett in your recent
conversation with Eric you said the
unity plan quote is the best plan we've
got short term now the deepest plan we
have dot then you were cut off how can
you finish that thought
Mike apparently not yeah okay what I
would say I think what I'm was getting
at in that statement and you know it's
been days so who's to say but years and
years in 2020 time yeah but what I think
I was getting at is this we are talking
at this level about how to take a very
broken electoral system and hack our way
into it to be able to do enough useful
that things start moving in the right
direction
that's the reason for the Unity 2020
plan longer-term the question is well
what do you do having gained access how
can we make civilization more liberating
at the same time that we make it safer
right that's a readily doable thing we
we are what a systems theorist would say
we are stuck on a local optimum there
are higher places we could go that would
accomplish more of the
values that we all share but we can't
get there by virtue of the structure of
the system that keeps us on these little
low Peaks so how you address that is a
deeper question we have to storm the
cockpit but once we're in the cockpit
then there's a question about well
actually where do we really want to go
and I think you know I'm itching to have
that conversation because I know that we
can do better on almost every front that
people would want us to do better that
all decent people would agree would be a
positive change and how to do that
involves compiling people with the right
sorts of insight and having discussions
about what will work and you know if
you're hearing this thinking oh my god
he's a liberal he's gonna do some
do-gooder thing and it's gonna create
damage well now the whole point is look
liberals tend to miss the unintended
consequences of positive change so how
can you hedge out that risk so you can
move in a direction discover whether it
works
abort the progress in that direction if
it's not working these are all readily
doable
and we've lost track of it because we've
seen nothing but predatory governance
for most of our lives next question is
from echo who reliably asks excellent
questions this one I think due to
limitations of character count is a
little hard to parse so I'm gonna try
alright so she's referencing here the
Masters tools which is this Audrey Lorde
quote about you cannot use the Masters
tools to destroy the Masters house
something like that mental dismantle the
Masters house so is the Masters tools
idea confusing enlightenment tools with
IQ question mark if IQ is fitness for
specific intelligence skills link to the
function of modern functioning of modern
society the idea of other tools may be
to open new outcomes using other skill
sets might this be a misused statement
against conservatism mmm so much there
yeah that's a hard man to parse yeah I
would say look I'm sure there are
interpretations of this quote that can
be rescued but the problem is the quote
doesn't come with an instruction set so
even if it as it was delivered it made
sense the way it is now wielded and we
know this firsthand because we've seen
it done it is typically wielded against
things like science right the idea being
well that's your tool kit we're not
gonna be able to use that to get where
we need to go which is nonsense you know
as I have said many times you know where
the best tools are there in the masters
tool ship and for good reason for
obvious reasons right you want tools to
take apart two masters house the
master's tool shed is the place to find
them so we need to democratize those
tools we need to get them to as many
people as we can and teach them how to
wield them with great deafness and that
is the solution and to be told that it
is the opposite of the solution is
nothing but counterproductive yeah so I
mean I think and I'm sure echo would
agree with the idea that the Audrey
Lorde quote makes no sense but the more
I look at this the more I think that
what's being asked here is Arendt is it
possible in fact that there are more
things that humans can do than those
which have been privileged by the
current society in which we live and if
we look to some of the other skills that
humans might have might we build a
different kind of future that would be
in fact more just and free for everyone
oh of course there are tools that aren't
in the master's tool shed they're not in
anyone's tool shed and bootstrapping
them is a great idea I mean implied in
the Masters tools quote is we the
historically and and currently oppressed
have special access to those tools or
indeed we have had those tools all along
and you the dominant oppressor class
have kept us from using them and kept
them from being valued and there may be
some instances of that sort of maybe but
but the idea of none of the tools and
therefore none of the outcomes that we
are currently
with our valued or can have a place in
the future that we want to design or and
that we envision you know that that's
clearly heading towards dystopia very
quickly so I will say more in the future
about the term Dark Horse and why I
chose it but the basic idea is that the
Dark Horse which is a feature of a story
I think I've talked about this before
written by Benjamin Disraeli the Dark
Horse has been trained in secret and
therefore no one knows how to bet on it
because they don't know what it's
capable of
so that dark is not a reference to its
color well it is dark just by
happenstance but but it's a metaphorical
meaning of its darkness is more
important in the story yes right so the
point that I'm making is that that very
metaphor suggests that there are tools
beyond the common ones right and that
those tools every so often emerge and
they change things so you know the
Fosbury flop for example changed
high-jumping I don't know that
high-jumping is particularly important
but the point is something enters and
everything changes and you know same
could be said for black people in many
sports including baseball as Matt Taibbi
was discussing in his takedown of white
fragility anyway there's lots to be said
for that which we do not know because
our vision is limited to that which we
expect yes absolutely there are tools
beyond what the master has and yes those
might be even more useful but don't
neglect the tools in your shed because
they're awfully good I've heard you say
that memes must be subservient to jeans
but also that we must rebel against no
jeans wouldn't rebelling against our
jeans be a set of memes help me
reconcile the contradiction well no I
think your question reveals that you get
the problem it's not a simple one we are
wired such that our cultural nature is
subservient to our genetic nature but if
you can hear this podcast you can also
hear me say if you knew what your genes
were willing to do in the service of
spreading them you'd throw up right no
it's absolutely despicable some of what
they want now some of what they want you
to do is absolutely beautiful
right but to choose that part of what
your genes want you to do that is
honorable and decent and fits who you
claim to be and to reject that part that
is despicable and destructive and not
who you want to be that's the sweet spot
so you're already in rebellion right now
the question is not can your vow of
course you can repeal the question is
can you rebel without providing an
advantage to those who don't rebel those
who will do everything their genes want
them to do that's the deep question I
don't think anybody knows for sure what
the answer to that question is I can
tell you that I don't know of any reason
that that is impossible but I do not
think it is a simple process we have to
figure out how it is that we rebel
against the portion of what our genes
want us to do that does not fit our
understanding of ourselves without
providing advantage to those who refuse
to join us in that process and as far as
I see either we figure that out or we're
cooked courageous capable Patriots if
not McRaven yang you too would fit the
criteria for unity 2020 with flying
colors thank you both for your bravery
thank you um yeah I I see it it doesn't
it's gonna be on the left dude have you
seen my political compass test yeah no
you're a little bit farther left than I
am yeah thanks here's the thing first of
all a you me ticket doesn't fit one of
the features of the plan right why I
said who's gonna be on the left oh I see
yeah I'm not a plausible Republican no
you are not no you are not a plausible
Republican I'm not plausible democrat
anymore either right yeah me neither so
yeah thank you but it it doesn't it
doesn't work for this plan yep yeah Hale
professors no now professor Weinstein
don't hate the player hate the game we
should focus on structural change to
maximize opportunity for everyone in my
opinion I know that's a reference to I
don't know either but I mean I agree
yeah it's all about the structure of the
game you want people to behave well
build a game in which behaving well puts
you ahead I mean that's the whole thing
so elsewhere let's see in the
4th frontier talk that I gave I
described the following principle you've
got two kinds of systems right you're
one side of this divide or the other on
one side of the divide you've got a
system where the costs of keeping
civilization running belong to the good
people these are systems in which
personal responsibility dictates what
gets done those systems evolve towards
ruthlessness whereas if you make a
system in which the cost of keeping
civilization running go to the [ __ ]
they evolve towards benevolence decency
wonderfulness beauty all the things that
you would want so really the only big
question is which side of that divide is
your system on if it's on the wrong side
can you move it and the farther you move
it in that direction the faster it moves
in the direction you want it to go so
you can adjust the speed just by
figuring out okay to what degree do the
costs belong to the [ __ ] if the cost
belong entirely to the [ __ ] you'll
move very quickly in the right direction
if they 50% belong to the [ __ ]
you'll move half as fast so anyway this
isn't that tough once you reduce it to
its elements but mostly we're just going
to argue about whether am I saying so is
the result of some sort of deep-seated
racism that must pervade my thinking
because of the color of my skin or some
other nonsense right here's a donation
for guitar lessons smiley face thanks
very much for the continuing example in
two areas one faith and science and
reason to presumably is for you Brett
being a respectful and patient little
brother ah next question you had a plan
for mitigating the spoiler effect of
your unity 2020 plan what is this plan
yeah there are two things that mitigate
the spoiler effect one is the left right
part of this and by the way I need to
come back to the fact some people some
small fraction of people are thrown by
the fact that it says that we want
somebody from the center left and the
center right and people are like
centrism sucks which I agree it does but
that is not what we're doing this is not
a tepid plan the plan is about the
center because that is where you meet in
order to do things like save the
Republic can I interrupt here and say
you so you've said this thing about
centers and before and it got
it struck me as strange and it struck a
few other people who commented as strays
what's wrong with centrism and I think
back to your point I don't remember who
you said it was but said you know
there's 84 percent of us who aren't at
the exceed six percent 86 percent of us
are hidden tribes report oh it's hidden
drops okay since 86 percent of us who
aren't at one of these extremes that
seem to be driving policy and
conversation at the at the national and
international level now 86 percent is
there for the center oh so you know
you're not you're not left out of that
you know you're not to the left of that
86 percent well no I think my left ISM
doesn't make sense to people because
they don't understand what it is so I am
describing myself as a radical because I
believe only radical change will save us
that we are in a bad I'm a radical in
the same way that somebody who wants to
storm the cockpit of a plane in which
the pilot has just died is a radical
therefore radical action you're not
allowed a storm the cockpit well we're
gonna [ __ ] die if we don't do it so
I'm a radical right but I've also said I
want to live in a civilization that's so
good I can afford to be a conservative
right because I want that civilization
that's so good that I wanted to stay I
want to be against change because change
is very likely to be going to make it
worse so and there are many features of
our society that you do feel as do I are
very good and should not be changed or
dismantled absolutely in fact a huge
fraction so the reactionary thing isn't
across the board burn it all down wait
that's the thing if you went through my
belief system I'm sure some of its wrong
but if you went through it you'd find a
weird grab bag of places where I'm like
yeah let's go we've got to change that
and you know that thing better stick
even though most of the people who are
in theory on my side of this debate
would disagree
so you'll find an eclectic mix of things
based on independently arrived at
conclusions about what causes the thing
to work which is the definition of not
being an ideologue yes it's also you
have you have you and I as well and your
brother and many other people have
generated our our thoughts and our
positions based as much as possible
deriving them from first principles in
each of the cases as opposed to adopting
a slate an entire platform from the dams
the Republicans and the libertarians the
greens or whoever it is right it's taken
them issue by issue and saying what is
it that I actually think about this as
opposed to oh my friends think these
other three things that I agree with
maybe I should just agree with them on
all the rest yeah it's also the
definition of liberalism right this is
what liberal mindedness he is so back to
the question about the spoiler effect by
taking somebody from the center left and
the center right we do not spoil for
either party
so the typical spoiler derives from that
party to which it is closest and
therefore awards power to the party that
is farther away in this case splitting
both tickets
it harms both parties which is good
because the parties suck okay so that's
one way the other way is that built into
the plan is a mechanism whereby if the
ticket is not viable as the election
approaches we pull the plug on it all
right so the point is we can revert to
that prior state you don't have to worry
about signing on because you're not
going to be responsible for some
horrible outcome either this thing is
capable of going the distance or it
isn't
so one thing that occurs to me maybe
this isn't the place to raise it but
it's harder to do that
in the era of mail-in voting that when
everyone is voting actually on the same
day you can actually watch things and
pull the plug last minute for instance
and you can't do that as much like I
don't I don't know what the mailing but
voting for the national election will
look like in terms of the time span but
I know for the the primaries here in
Oregon we had like three or four weeks
yeah and so that that obviously in the
month before a national election in the
US so many things change October
Surprise is a standard piece of the
puzzle right this is why we have not
been specific about the mechanism is
that we don't know the full detail of
the world we're living in and so that we
can't build the failsafe with precision
yet but we are very committed to the
failsafe we understand this is one of
the top two concerns of people who are
interested in the plan but skeptical of
it and so anyway it's top of mind and
stay tuned and have I mentioned that you
should follow our accounts and send us
your email
that would be really helpful it would
help us show that we have the momentum
and momentum is the name of the game all
right
hey Bretton Heather can the Dark Horse
podcast be classified as an evolutionary
stable attractor also I am from
America's little brother Canada woods
signing up for the unity 2020 movement
helped the cause in any way yes
absolutely okay so first question list
that was an easy answer to the second
one can it be classified as an
evolutionarily stable attractor I don't
know it depends we [ __ ] it up I guess
but the I think I don't know I don't
know how to I don't have to do this one
yes it's it's joke ish but yeah it's a
little tough I mean I would say so far
seems good evolutionarily stable implies
cannot be displaced by any competing
podcast and while I would like to think
that is the case we do not know what
other strategies may be out there yeah
so yeah I don't know did that work Frank
so this is I just checked the previous
Q&A stream my question was will I unite
us and I was reading at Joseph
Campbell's hero with a thousand faces -
are there any other interesting books
that you guys are reading so many and
you know when I'm asked to sort a
question I never remember the names of
any of them but I will say that one book
this is not gonna seem in keeping it all
but it's the it's one of the books that
occurred to me and because no one will
be expecting it here maybe it will be it
will impress people to go look at it
that I have recently dipped back into
it's a book I read in full many years
ago actually it's it's a twofer here the
book that I read that everyone will be
familiar with is and in the art of
motorcycle maintenance by per-say
grobart for sake I think which just has
some gems of you know philosophical and
scientific thought running throughout
but of course it's very very thick and
then there's sort of a latter-day update
if you will to that I don't think the
author calls it that but Michael
Crawford I believe is his name wrote
he's written two terrific books the one
I'm thinking of his shop craft as
Soulcraft
which speaks to this point that I've
made many times as I view the not just
the virtue but the value in doing
physical work with real physical
outcomes as a way to train your mind to
be better at problem-solving so shop
craft as Soulcraft by Michael Crawford
is one of the books that I'm thinking
about at the moment yeah I have a good
answer to this I am not reading anything
I would recommend I would say probably
there is value in things like watching
the movie Brazil reading 1984 an animal
farm brave new world none of these
things are right on the money
but a lot of them will reveal that we
have seen elements of this in many
different combinations before and people
have spotted it and they've figured out
how to describe it and you know above
all else you need to be able to keep
your thinking straight in an era where
people are telling you a lot of false
things and insisting that they are so
true that no one could possibly disagree
and having an awareness a narrative
awareness that that is a common pattern
and that it is dangerous and that
basically one is entitled not to take
that stuff in deeply when it comes
probably worthwhile so I don't know how
useful a suggestion but something that's
probably if you're looking for something
to do it's probably a good good
investment yeah do you think a heroic
dose of psilocybin might leave Trump
with some appreciable amount of human
empathy something that has been
noticeably lacking thus far I love the
term heroic dose it was like yeah
totally with a lot of peanut butter or
something else so he doesn't know what
he's eaten yeah it's hard to sneak in a
heroic dose of silicide I cannot I I can
neither confirm nor deny that this is
part of the unity 2020 plan so I'll just
leave it at that
that's what's gonna cancel us right
that's it and that's it okay that's it
according to the Neanderthal genome
project ninety-nine point seven percent
of human in the a turtle DNA is
identical a current in nature
Asians and Europeans nature the magazine
that journal according to nature Asians
and Europeans inherited 1.5 22.1% Niren
tell DNA how do we square these facts oh
it's it's it's this question so the
thumb wait go ahead I usually think
about this and then have sort of a
twelve minute or so description on board
and I haven't thought about this in a
while but similarly we're 98 percent
similar to chimps but but it's also true
that our son zach is 50% related to each
of us all right so those are both true
numbers and that tells you that those
aren't the same percentages yeah right
so human and Neanderthal DNA is in fact
very very very closely aligned but
within that I'm just accepting your
numbers here that you've written out at
that point 3 percent the distinguishes
human from the ANATEL DNA I don't know
if these are actually based on whole
genomes or if they're just do an exon so
it's there's a whole there's a there's a
whole load of reasons to suspect these
numbers because modern genetic analysis
and genomic analysis is not nearly as
good and as the people doing it would
have you believe but assuming that the
number is close to right that still
lives 0.3% that is clearly and patently
different in the parts of the genome
anyway that we're looking at between
humans and Neanderthals and you can then
look at that part and and look at
whether or not and I remembered it was
Europeans I didn't know Asians but the
Europeans clearly have some of the DNA
from Neanderthals that is not otherwise
shared between humans and Neanderthals
whereas for instance Africans don't so
you're basically looking that my guess
is that just looking at these two
percentages that 1.5 22.1% that
Europeans have inherited of near tall
DNA is one point five to two point one
percent of the part of the genome that
is not share
between humans Neanderthals yep I have
very little to add other than at the end
of the process of this genetic exchange
who also have selection which is going
to adjust what you see in other winter
selections so you could have had genes
move that then went extinct because in
the place that they moved to that they
were disfavored so anyway which is part
of why these are it's these are
estimates at best
yep okay we're an hour and 15 minutes
we're gonna do four more questions okay
okay but two of them are just comments I
am looking forward to your talk with
David Sloan Wilson I am emailing your
mod with a link to a paper that explores
a theory of human evolution which
modifies Hamilton's law without invoking
group selection Dorito yeah sounds like
my kind of thing okay we don't care
about 4th July in the UK do it okay
we're doing it okay but we're gonna make
you care about it you don't need to hear
about the 4th of July I have to tell you
resistance is useless and you will be
assimilated yeah ok ok I'm gonna read
the I'm gonna be slightly out of order
because what would be the last question
isn't a great place to end
good question big fan guys I'm a
well-known marketer built my email list
240k real quick happy to help you guys
no cost I have some ways that will work
to scale up your list real quick so good
actually
if you sir would email the darkhorse
email like send that send that email
yeah go to articles of unity dot org
that will take you to a medium post and
at the bottom of it there is a an email
link so add your email and then email
the link with your your details yeah
final question
in I have to interpret this I'm gonna
read it just as it is first in culture /
consciousness consciousness progressive
is suited for tackling novelty so this
is like a synopsis of our argument with
regard to the the dueling dichotomy
between culture and consciousness in
Heights righteous mind progressive
strongly value the care harm moral
foundation is care and harm optimized
for novelty Wow we may go to one more
question after this because I don't feel
in a good position I would have to go
review what Hyde had said I do think but
I'm gonna yeah I'd have to review the
righteous mind both read it but it's
been a while
this idea that progressives are more
likely to invoke issues of harm to
others and caring for others than people
on the right side of the aisle are is
pretty robust finding from psychology I
think and I don't know that there's
particular particularly an overlap here
and I don't think actually that this the
model that we have presented have
written about and presented in our
Princeton talk and and such about
culture versus consciousness culture
being about maintaining extant values
that have been important in the past and
may continue to be important but not in
times of great change and consciousness
being what you invoke and need during
times of change and when when you need
creativity that is about that's about
sort of population level strategies that
can exist in in minds as opposed to
progressive people who identify as
progressive sort of regardless of
whether or not things actually need to
change or not tend to have more focus on
caring for others and harm
to others and I may be the distinction
here is exactly this that the the thing
that you've just said and that you've
said many times before that you are
progressive and I believe this too but
you you have been the first person to
say it you were progressive who
desperately wants to live in a world in
which you could call yourself a
conservative that that points to
actually the pot the ideological problem
with saying I'm just I'm just a
progressive or I'm just a conservative
yeah right and so this culture
consciousness model is specifically an
evolutionary model because it identifies
the fact that conditions change and as
conditions change so must strategies if
they're going to be effective well you
can get it you can get there two
different ways yeah you can either
default to listening to the people who
are on the side of the spectrum that
matches the area you're in but that's
hugely wasteful yeah right the better
way is for people to recognize what era
they're in and to move from whether they
are trying to conserve the structure or
or upend it based on whether or not it
is working or it's come to a dead end
mm-hmm
let's say let's find one more question a
couple just buying you a beer bro nice
little something to hopefully help get
you out of the gig economy just Brit
Bret say thanks to you brother for the
encouragement okay one last question oh
it's a small one this is easy no it's
not slightly off-topic but given the
state of higher ed would either of you
or other members of the IDW ever
consider building a potential parallel
educational institution what yeah we've
been on such a project and a moment it
is suspended for reasons but yeah we
would be excited about the prospect of
architecting something new that didn't
suck that's kind of the objective
education but not sucky
yeah that's a great tagline I think
actually we'll just stop there then all
right well thanks everybody this has
been great fun don't forget to sign up
for the Articles of unity
Twitter handle send us your email
address
be well oh you might also like and
subscribe and respond in the comments to
the to the live stream here and if you
want to participate in long
conversations with brett has patreon go
to his and if you want to get included
in private monthly community live
streams come to my patreon yeah and if
you want to be sent to Mars sign up
before Elon Musk's Twitter all right see
you all it's been great
we'll be back in the 4th of July
[Music]
[Music]